Hey hey guys I'm Greg Greg Greg this is
Mary number on when you introduce your
video is like I don't know what's gonna
happen it's very exciting very never up
Collider videos P Nemiroff on Twitter
and Instagram to really make this work
for a while fuller on or social media
please you guys have already heard of
Collider videos go on her social media
that would mean the world to me and say
Greg sent me here I will respond and say
yes he did hey Perry yes there's the
trailer I'm sorry okay it's a Full Metal
Alchemist you guys got reacted a little
hours trailer starring dave Franco
Audrey Plaza
that's right Armisen it looks really
funny I don't know about those I don't
know about this no it's gonna be a brand
of human I feel like this played at a
festival that this play at Sundance and
I don't think people were talking about
it
well that might mean a small pony but I
like that cat will to red band trailer
so maybe all those jokes are in the
Train so fine a fun for the trailer it's
not moving quickly
[Music]
whoa whoa careful morning sister brother
sister Fernanda sister Alessandro sister
Miranda to do your sins
bling bling [ __ ] do my own thing [ __ ]
building conversation mind your own
[ __ ] business
[Music]
no you're wrong you're right
wake up no you can't what effect goes to
be tough I'm not going to lie very tough
with another man place she would say
around my sex autonomy which just went
along with Senate rated a we're also
song right did you do that I did
[Music]
be sublingual kerosene eating blood do
you have the Bourbon indemnity blood
being formed one bling-bling [ __ ] for
my own thing [ __ ] wedding ring that
being a lyrical interesting hi
so was it as worrisome as you expected
it to me I didn't laugh out loud all
that much but at the same time it's
watching people like Aubrey Plaza
actually where six is a scenario I kind
of want to see it I kind of want to see
it too because I I grew up heavily
Catholic it's like the complete sinful
vision have you ever seen a life after
bet no I really like that little B in
that the director directed right it is
here with Aubrey Plaza oh I mean it kind
of reminds me of a much more contained
version of year one oh you know how it
was like oh it's five old days but we're
gonna make it like modern day dialogue
that's the only movie I've ever walked
out of but it's not because I thought it
was the worst thing in the world it's
because I went to a midnight screening
and I got really tired wrong like I have
to go home now
understandably yeah but I never gave it
a second shot well I don't feel bad I
rented it and didn't finish it okay it's
pretty bad yeah but you're dropping that
off the list now I think because this is
more contained specifically about like
this group of nuns who are vulgar and
loved to swear and love to have sex and
do all these crazy things and they're
angry violent women I didn't have kind
of a funny concept but also seeing like
Nick Offerman and like everyone has the
modern-day personality and good like a
sketch there's a long a sketch it does
feel like a long sketch I wonder what
the runtime is on executory see 2014
well if it's anything over 90 I imagine
the joke would grow tired yeah
it's working in the Strand this was also
a really well cut trailer I think I like
the music choice and most of the time
when you have little quote blobs that
pop up in the village but I don't know
why I call them gloves but it feels you
know obviously they're going to do that
here it works yeah yeah and I like when
they put on the one from the Catholic
yeah I don't know whatever my concern is
what you said about how sorry guys it's
4:20 today and my members not as strong
as they can be about how it's 100 how'd
you know oh she a girl and how does one
joke and it's like I don't know how long
I'll find this one joke funny because it
does feel like this could would have
been fine as like a five-minute sketch I
don't know if I can watch a whole movie
that's all this the same basic joke like
doing Catholicism rituals but but make
it in modern day personalities really ii
didn't have this massive all-star roster
of people that I loved I would probably
be thinking right now that it's going to
do this joke to death but when you add
all those people I imagine every time
someone pops up it's got to get fresh
and fresh and okay oh I don't know how
her eyes to look on the bright side but
so I did a little Sundance Laurel at the
beginning and I don't think that this
was very talked about well that doesn't
look like a Sundance kind of crap no
it's open
not at all very specific people when you
premiere at home festival and you don't
get buzz it's probably nine notice
that's a fair that's a fair expect to
point out here but still you did point
out how everyone looks like it'll
probably make it fresh every time
someone showed up I was a good point I
can see why you work for a Collider
video oh well because you are an
intelligent one you you you open mine
because there is aw man you open my eyes
to say the intelligent part again just
in case to cut up okay ready go you are
an intelligent beautiful woman Perry I
added that
nice things so you can always re-edit
you know whichever one sounds more
confident more you can just put the both
important there you know yeah why my
cutout videos who needs to edit and I
forgot the whole thing I was going to
say okay so I think you're super kind
and funny and you're looking for the
damn good I say you're wrong
they are running where we're gonna run
we're going to train in on the bloody
marathon yes you run away lifts you
cross it drops but this morning damn
your own stuff I go to LA Fitness
village in yeah CrossFit no no I do baby
CrossFit so I'm afraid of the full
CrossFit classes I do you know the
cardio classes this little infant
survival stuff like that that's cool
challenge there is a kid's class and I
really want to take a nap Oh - I can see
them they're all working out on the
board I'm like that looks like fun I
wonder if they'll let me do it they want
well they're easy to do any kids profit
class people go join a class or whether
hey subscribe to the real rejects P
Nemiroff on Twitter and Instagram
Perry Nemiroff in the rest of the world
announcer actual name TV fights champion
one day we'll verse each other in the
showdown oh I think it's so competitive
and heartbreaking every single time
someone brings a Schmo down I start to
sweat this is awful
much happening I have nightmares about
that thing I don't like it I want to be
better at it I don't like losing and I
suck
you don't suck you can smell very awful
in the free-for-alls
I should see me I got one point I don't
what we got one point we got one point
together wall John got like 57 oyster
yeah